ونوه فقط لهذا الخبر اذا العاجل بحسب
مراسلنا اصابه مباشره في مبنى من اربع
طوابق او اربع طوابق في
جنوبيه تل ابيب هذه الصور اذا تصلنا
مباشره من هناك او قبل قليل من هناك اذا
لهذه اذا الضربه
بالصواريخ قادمه من قطاع غزه
النجوان منطقه اذن تشهد المزيد من الاحداث
نشاهدها في هذه الصور هل لديك اي معلومات
متوفره بشانها
نجوى هل تسمعينه
نعم سفيان نعم نعم اذا اصابه مباشره على
ما يبدو في مبنى من اربع طوابق في حفوض
جنوبيه تل ابيب هل من معلومات
بالفعل بدات تصل صور اوليه من موقع اصابه
هذه البنايه السكنيه في مدينه التي تقع
الى الجنوب من مدينه تل ابيب قرابه 20
كيلومتر عن تل ابيب هناك اصابه مباشره
لاحد المباني السكنيه من عده طوابق هناك
ايضا انباء عن اصابه لاحدى
المستوطنات هناك ولكن هذه معلومه غير
مؤكده بعد من جهات طبيه في الجانب
الاسرائيلي لكن ترد معلومات عن اصابات هي
معلومات اوليه وغير مؤكده لكن نرى حجم
الدمار
الذي حصل جراء هذه الاصابه المباشره في
ريخوفت
وكانت هناك عده قذائف صاروخيه قد اطلقت
قبل قليل باتجاه هذه المناطق
ان منظومه القبه الحديديه لم تتمكن من
اعتراض هاديه هذه القذيفه او هذا الصاروخ
في مدينه ريخوفت الاسرائيليه وعليه من
الواضح ان هناك اصابه هذه ليست المره
الاولى بطبيعه الحال الذي تحدث فيه اصابات
مباشره لبنايات سكنيه خلال هذه المعركه
يوم امس كانت هناك ايضا اصابه لبنايه
سكنيه في مدينه عسقلان لمنازل في بلده
ازديروت في حدود الشماليه الشرقيه مع
الحدود مع غزه في المنطقه الحدوديه
الشرقيه الشماليه اذا حاليا
هذه الانباء ترد عن اصابه مباشره وهناك
يبدو تاكيد ايضا عن اصابه احد
الاسرائيليين جراء هذه
هذه القذيفه التي سقطت على مبنى سكني في
رخوبه اذن بالفعل هناك اصابه لاحد
الاسرائيليين في جراء سقوط هذه القذيفه
على احد المباني السكنيه في ريخوفت وبحسب
الصور التي تصل من هناك هناك دمار كبير في
الموقع ومره اخرى
تفشل او تخفق منظومه القبه الحديديه التي
تعترض
القذائف او الصواريخ التي تطلق من قطاع
غزه باعتراض هذه
القذائف رغم ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن
نجاح يصل الى اكثر من 95 في المئه لهذه
المنظومه والغريب ربما سفيان ان هذه
الرشقه او على الاقل حتى حتى الان حتى هذه
اللحظه لم يعلن عن كميه القذائف التي
اطلقت بنفس اللحظه لان عاده ما يربك
منظومه القبه الحديديه هو رشقه
كبيره او عده صواريخ ودفعات كبيره
لقضاء الصاروخيه تطلق دفعه واحده باتجاهات
مختلفه وعلى مرتفعات مختلفه هذا عاده ما
يربك منظومه القبه الحديديه التي تفشل في
تحديد وجهه هذه الصواريخ ربما كانت بالفعل
هذه رشقه
كثيفه من الصواريخ ولكن حتى الان لا يوجد
عدد للرصد الذي من الجانب الاسرائيلي لعدد
الصواريخ التي اطلقت باتجاه هذه المناطق
هذه المناطق دوت فيها صافرات الانذار قبل
قليل وتلاها ذوي انفجارات سمعناه من هذه
المنطقه حيث نتواجد في مدينه تل ابيب
رشقت جديده تصل من القطاع الى تل ابيب
وتفشل المنظومات الاسرائيليه في اعتراضها
سنعود ربما اليك لاحقا للمزيد من التفاصيل